Elon must dream this year was Dei must
die and it sounds like the billionaire
might get his wish major attack giants
like Google and meta are quietly
slashing their diversity equity and
inclusion programs this year and laying
off workers in those departments in fact
Dei related job postings declined 44% by
the middle of this year compared to 2022
Academia however is a different story
critics argue that the only reason why
Harvard's president Claudine gay has
kept her job despite two scandals over
anti-Semitism and plagiarism is because
of the University's focus on
Dei um Kenedy I want to start with you
on this so Dei jobs have been around a
long time sure they just after the
murder of George Floyd which just got
this huge surge I think indeed said
there was a 56% jump um in terms of the
listings for it how how can we keep the
parts of the system that are important
and get rid of The Virtue signaling
aspects of it so I I think what happened
is a lot of these companies were
responding because they felt the
backlash and you know they could look
and see that there was indeed systemic
racism that has been with this country
for hundreds of years but the way
they're tackling it is wrong because
it's actually very divisive so if you
work at a big company and you deploy
teams who are supposed to work together
but implicitly you are dividing people
by race that's bad for business because
people won't be able to coales if they
naturally see another person as their
enemy because of their immutable
characteristics so for that reason it
has been bad for the bottom line for
other companies they are downsizing
they're cutting a lot of jobs in Tech so
they look at this and you know this is
an enormous basket where a lot of
resources have gone but it it has not
improved the bottom line it hasn't
improved morale so you have to move on
from it and you have to admit maybe this
is not the way to improve the system
maybe you're actually creating more of
systemic struggles and teaching people
in your company how to sue you bang good
point would you like to make a good
point yourself I mean I try I think
Harvard's president said it best when
she said ask not what your country can
do for you you can do for your country
and she's right she's right the only
thing we have to fear is fear itself
okay here's the problem with Dei for
real if you want to know the reason
businesses are walking away from it is
it's also crushing their bottom line
from this standpoint it takes the focus
away from what actually makes companies
profitable like if you're a hamburger
company you make money selling
hamburgers you don't make money catling
catering to these old social justice
struggles on the side I think Disney
learned this the hardest Disney is in
the business of plating parents and kids
who want to go on vacation and as they
quickly found out no kid is waiting in
line three hours to ride Peter Pan
sexual okay they wanted Peter Pan they
wanted regular everyday life Disney's
business was not social justice and
that's why you see Iger trying to
backtrack so I think that's the
long-term solution is if you wanted to
help you go back to Mad Men remember Mad
Men where they catered to the customer
preferences Dei is mad them they took
Dawn Draper made him Dawn Draper and all
the customers are miserable because
they're not getting what they want how
come I'm Jimmy fa don't worry about it
you don't need to know I'm still back on
the Gaza Strip as a strip
club Katie what do you think happens to
Claud gay
in all this it doesn't seem over she's
going be I think she is a a very
specific public example based on her
testimony and her plagiarism but that's
not the big issue here the big issue is
that a lot of these corporations decided
they wanted to engage in virtue
signaling by implementing Dei but Dei
forces you to discriminate against
people based on their race based on
their gender and they're about to get
sued and they've been threatened with
lawsuits because doing that is violation
of the Civil Rights Act so in this
effort to be more diverse and to uh
engage in Dei they have inherently
discriminated against entire classes of
people Academia does this as well and
there have been lawsuits against Harvard
for example for taking applicants of
Asian students and throwing them out the
window because they happen to be Asian
students in favor of others so this
whole process and system that they built
forces them to discriminate which is not
what they're supposed to do and actually
illegal so they're walking this back and
saying it's a bottom line issue but it's
also an issue of Fair Labor practices
and not violating the laws that are
already on the books about
discrimination all for Fair Labor
practices but a denial of the fact that
there are systemic challenges that
affect certain groups seems impossible
but this is the challenge though they're
not addressing them on a merit-based
level and that's why it's backfiring on
them you could address these systemic
challenges by putting the most qualified
people in the positions the problem we
have at Harvard right now is she's
clearly not the most qualified person
but they made the bed and they can't
fire her because that's an abandonment
of the whole thing so I mean I'd be all
for any of like when I get on a plane I
don't care who's flying the plane but I
want to know that they can fly it when I
ever whenever I get on a plane for real
me and Lincoln were just flying to
Dallas and like up here in the cockpit
we have the most diverse crew in the
Delta Fleet I'm like I'm getting off the
plane okay that does I want to hear I'm
a cranky ex-military pilot and we got to
connect and the guy in the flight deck
needs to let us go or he's going to have
a problem I want a guy who knows how to
do the gig you you make a good point the
only way to fix any of it is through
education and you have to start at the
beginning and you have to provide uh
Stellar education to everybody no matter
what their income level is or where
where uh what their background is and
that's of course what you know you know
school choice is such an important
aspect of all of that and for some
reason Democrats and unions uh fight
that tooth and nail but if you want to
bring equality and parity to everybody
you do it by educating everybody uh so
that they can perform y this is one of
the many reasons I turned down a
scholarship to Harvard you know what get
your act together I'm going to nasso
community I got other options and you
really showed them okay Pizza Hut is
ditching delivery drivers Justice
California hikes its minimum wage to $20
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else